Trascrizione: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: SILVIA ALLONE
Eccoci qua.
Allora, io parlerò della vista,
questo regalo immenso
che ci è stato donato alla nascita
e che abbiamo il dovere, il diritto
di conservare nel miglior modo possibile,
perché più noi riusciamo
a conservare in maniera eccellente
il nostro apparato visivo,
più riusciamo a integrarci nel mondo,
perché la visione è determinante
nel far sì che ci si possa integrare
e vivere la nostra realtà.
Dunque quello di cui noi parleremo oggi
è come siamo riusciti a curare
o a risolvere determinate problematiche
per una patologia che coinvolge,
praticamente, l'apparato visivo,
quindi l'occhio;
e che cosa si è riusciti a fare
grazie all'innovazione tecnologica.
Il problema è piuttosto grande,
perché ogni anno 50.000 persone
si ammalano di questa malattia,
che, a differenza di altre malattie,
difficilmente poteva essere
curata precedentemente,
perché se noi paragoniamo l'occhio
ad una macchina fotografica,
la parte che in questo caso
si va ad ammalare
è la parte più importante
dell'occhio, che è la retina.
La retina rappresenta -
se la dovessimo paragonare
ad una macchina fotografica -
la pellicola;
e quando la pellicola è rovinata,
difficilmente può essere riparata.
Molto più facile,
se la causa della riduzione
della nostra capacità visiva
è legata a una opacità del cristallino,
quindi se il cristallino si opacizza,
è molto più facile cambiare l'obiettivo
del nostro apparato visivo,
anche se, come era successo
già negli anni Ottanta,
questo problema nel mettere un corpo nuovo
all'interno del cristallino
aveva creato non poche controversie.
Che cosa succede
quando noi siamo ammalati,
o c'è un problema alla retina,
o c'è un problema alla macula?
Il problema è che la macula
serve per vedere nel dettaglio,
la macula serve per poter leggere.
Se la macula è praticamente ammalata,
soprattutto se questo succede
in entrambi gli occhi,
la lettura diventa difficoltosa.
Allora è come se noi
guardassimo in faccia una persona
e la vedessimo sfocata,
e al centro della faccia
apparisse una macchia nera,
quindi diventa estremamente complicato
riuscire a correggere
una situazione particolare come questa.
Allora, per riuscire a capire
quello che è il sistema, il progetto,
la progettualità di quello
che siamo andati a creare,
se noi paragonassimo il nostro
apparato visivo, quindi l'occhio,
ad una macchina fotografica,
la parte anteriore, che è composta
dalla cornea, l'iride e il cristallino,
potrebbe essere paragonata immediatamente
al nostro obiettivo
della macchina fotografica;
la camera vitrea, che è
la parte centrale dell'occhio,
la possiamo paragonare
alla camera intermedia
della macchina fotografica;
e la retina, che è la parte
più profonda dell'occhio,
la possiamo, come abbiamo detto prima,
paragonare alla pellicola fotografica.
Quindi, se andiamo a rivedere
come è formato l'occhio,
vediamo che l'occhio è formato
quasi come una macchina fotografica,
e la macula rappresenta
quella parte profonda, un po' giallina,
che riusciamo a vedere nello schermo,
e che rappresenta quello che è
il dettaglio della visione.
Quindi, tutto quello che è
il dettaglio della visione
viene praticamente espresso, viene visto
in quell'area molto piccola, giallognola,
che sta a fianco al nostro nervo ottico.
Certamente, dato che è
una zona molto piccola,
quando è lesionata potrebbe essere
un problema andarla a curare.
Parlare di macula, parlare di maculopatia
è un po' una cosa non tanto semplice,
perché è come se noi paragonassimo
una maculopatia a un incidente.
Un incidente può essere
di un'entità piccola
o di un'entità devastante;
e anche qui, in questo caso,
la maculopatia può andare
da una piccola lesione
a una grande lesione.
Quando è una piccola lesione,
più o meno non ci si può rendere conto
che abbiamo un problema patologico
che si sta sviluppando;
ma quando questo problema
evolve nel tempo,
certamente il nostro apparato visivo
comincia a ridurre la sua capacità visiva.
La macula rappresenta
il target di massima visione,
quindi dove si sviluppa la maggior visione
quando noi guardiamo un oggetto
o quando noi vogliamo andare a leggere,
quindi rappresenta, anche,
quella che è l'entità
di quello che ci permette
di poter vedere anche tutti i colori.
Quindi se la macula è ammalata,
naturalmente nasce il problema,
nasce la maculopatia.
La maculopatia,
che fino a qualche anno fa
non si poteva curare
perché non c'erano i mezzi,
poi piano piano
sono intervenuti i primi mezzi
ma comunque sì, risolvevano il problema,
ma lasciando sempre
qualche altro problema legato,
quindi c'erano dei pro e dei contro
da tenere sempre bene in considerazione
e, per quanto riguarda la maculopatia,
dobbiamo ricordare sempre
che esistono vari tipi di maculopatia.
Esiste una maculopatia di tipo essudativo,
una maculopatia di tipo secco
e una maculopatia di tipo degenerativo.
Fortunatamente, per quanto riguarda
la patologia maculare di tipo essudativo
si è riusciti, con alcuni farmaci,
a risolvere in maniera eccellente
questo problema;
ma rimaneva sempre il problema
legato alla maculopatia di tipo atrofico,
piuttosto che degenerativo.
E cosa succede,
quando la macula è ammalata?
Allora noi vediamo sopra
che abbiamo una macula che è perfetta,
un occhio eccellente,
una macula straordinaria,
questo del resto
è un ragazzo molto giovane,
mentre in basso vediamo
che l'area dell'occhio
contrapposto a quello sopra
è un'area interessata
da un'atrofia maculare.
Questo purtroppo è un occhio
che alla nascita, per esempio,
ha avuto un'infezione
ed è andato incontro
ad una cicatrizzazione dell'area maculare.
Allora noi cosa possiamo fare?
Possiamo cercare
di risolvere questo problema,
chiaramente non possiamo
sostituire la retina,
cosa che potremmo fare, per esempio,
in una macchina fotografica;
perché non possiamo sostituirla?
Perché non abbiamo ancora
i mezzi di collegamento
per la sostituzione della retina;
possiamo, se la lesione è piccola,
fare un intervento chirurgico
di spostamento della retina,
ma quando la lesione, per esempio,
è così di vasta entità questo
non è possibile eseguirlo.
Allora abbiamo cercato
di realizzare un sistema
che ci permettesse
di ingrandire le immagini
nell'eventualità -
dato che questo sistema
è un sistema formato da due lenti
contrapposte una all'altra -
eventualmente se,
come abbiamo visto prima,
la lesione era piuttosto grande, estesa,
avessimo anche la possibilità,
nello stesso momento
della realizzazione del sistema,
di poter deviare anche l'immagine.
Certamente l'innovazione
tecnologica, in questo senso,
ci ha dato un grandissimo contributo,
perché oggi, a differenza di ieri,
si riesce a costruire
un sistema ingrandente miniaturizzato
e questo sistema
ingrandente miniaturizzato
può essere poi, una volta realizzato,
introdotto nell'occhio.
Certamente, sentire parlare di questo
può sembrare molto strano,
ma se noi ritorniamo indietro negli anni,
20 anni fa, quando si è parlato
di introdurre un cristallino artificiale
all'interno dell'occhio,
il mondo scientifico
ha urlato allo scandalo,
perché si diceva che, effettivamente,
non si sarebbe mai riusciti
a realizzare un cristallino
e che lo stesso potesse essere introdotto
all'interno dell'occhio.
Oggi, invece, sentiamo che tante persone
vengono operate di cataratta
e subito dopo l'intervento sono pronte
ad uscire dall'ambulatorio chirurgico,
togliere quella che è la benda
che è stata messa loro
per il decorso postoperatorio
e ritornare a vedere immediatamente bene.
Quindi la cosa che nasce oggi,
a 20 anni, 25 anni di distanza
da quel primo passaggio,
è lo stesso, cioè un'innovazione
tecnologica straordinaria
che permette a queste persone,
che hanno una lesione maculare
di tipo atrofico nell'occhio,
di poter risolvere o migliorare
quella che è la loro capacità visiva.
Dobbiamo pensare che,
nel momento in cui riusciamo
a migliorare la capacità visiva
riusciamo a migliorare anche
quella che è la qualità di vita
e la qualità di vita, naturalmente,
coinvolge anche tutte le persone
che accompagnano, o sono vicine,
alle persone affette
da degenerazione maculare
o da una capacità involutiva
della visione.
Allora è stato realizzato
un primo progetto;
il primo progetto, come dicevamo prima,
prevedeva l'impianto,
all'interno dell'occhio,
di un doppio sistema:
un sistema miniaturizzato ingrandente,
che andava a deviare,
oppure a ingrandire l'immagine
favorendo o facilitando
la capacità visiva del paziente.
Adesso la grande, invece,
innovazione tecnologica cosa ha portato?
Da quel sistema si è realizzato
il sistema ingrandente miniaturizzato,
ma che va completamente introdotto
all'interno del sacco capsulare,
quindi va introdotto totalmente
al posto del vecchio cristallino.
Il vecchio cristallino viene rimosso,
viene lasciato solamente l'involucro
che avvolge la sostanza
propria del cristallino
e una volta che viene rimosso
viene introdotto, all'interno
del sacco capsulare,
il nuovo sistema
ingrandente miniaturizzato.
Il sistema ingrandente miniaturizzato,
come lo possiamo vedere,
può essere a linea diretta
oppure con la possibilità
di deviare l'immagine.
Certamente tutto questo,
prima di essere realizzato,
prima di portare il paziente
in sala operatoria,
c'è un percorso che permette di capire
quanto può essere aiutato il paziente,
quanto è il grado di miglioramento
che può ottenere il paziente
con il sistema
e se il sistema, che è leggermente
più grande di un cristallino naturale,
può essere introdotto
all'interno dell'occhio
e se possono esserci, o meno,
delle complicanze;
e viene fatta, prima ancora
dell'eventuale intervento chirurgico,
una simulazione
che permette di quantificare
il grado di miglioramento
della capacità visiva del paziente.
Ora possiamo vedere come,
una volta fatto l'intervento,
il doppio sistema
di cristallini incrociati
viene introdotto nell'occhio.
Ecco, vediamo, questa è la foto
che ci permette di vedere
come questo sistema,
che apparentemente sembrava
impossibile da realizzare,
impossibile da ottenere,
grazie all'innovazione tecnologica
è stato possibile introdurlo
all'interno dell'occhio.
È un'innovazione,
come giustamente diceva prima Gerolamo,
totalmente italiana:
in Italia vengono, quasi ogni mese,
chirurghi provenienti da tutto il mondo
per vedere questo sistema
e questa innovazione tecnologica.
È un sistema, per il momento,
di un grande successo,
perché anche all'ultimo congresso
dell'SCRS, che si è tenuto a Milano,
22 chirurghi provenienti da tutto il mondo
erano ospiti nel nostro ospedale
per vedere l'impianto
e per collaborare a quello che è
uno sviluppo internazionale del sistema
a livello mondiale.
Il risultato che noi
vogliamo ottenere qual è?
Quello di riuscire a migliorare
la qualità della vita del paziente,
di questi pazienti che, essendo affetti
da una degenerazione maculare
di tipo atrofico
non potrebbero trovare, con il farmaco,
una soluzione migliorativa
di quello che è il loro problema,
di quello che è il loro deficit visivo:
ma con un'applicazione,
all'interno dell'occhio,
di un sistema ingrandente miniaturizzato
che permette loro di avere
un ingrandimento dell'immagine,
hanno la possibilità, in questo caso,
di migliorare quella che è
la loro capacità visiva.
Il sistema è un sistema che,
una volta introdotto
all'interno dell'occhio,
risulta invisibile,
perché sia l'anello esterno,
sia la lente negativa
e sia la lente positiva
che in questo caso funge da obiettivo,
vengono introdotti totalmente
nel sacco capsulare,
che rappresenta praticamente lo spazio,
il contenuto del cristallino naturale;
e di conseguenza,
subito dopo l'intervento,
una volta che è stato introdotto
il sistema miniaturizzato ingrandente
nel sacco capsulare,
il paziente ha innanzitutto la possibilità
di percepire subito
un miglioramento visivo;
e soprattutto non ha il disagio
di far vedere un sistema antiestetico
come potrebbe essere, per esempio,
se lo stesso sistema, noi,
lo dovessimo applicare davanti all'occhio,
quindi su un occhiale;
perché lo stesso sistema che è
miniaturizzato all'interno dell'occhio,
davanti all'occhio,
quindi in una porzione esterna,
risulterebbe estremamente grande,
estremamente invasivo,
ma la grande differenza che ci sarebbe
è sostanzialmente nella capacità
del campo visivo,
perché se io lo stesso sistema
lo vado a mettere all'esterno dell'occhio
riduco notevolmente
quello che è il campo visivo,
cosa che invece, se lo metto
all'interno dell'occhio,
addirittura il campo visivo
viene amplificato.
È un'innovazione tecnologica,
secondo me, straordinaria,
che darà senz'altro dei grandi sviluppi.
L'interesse internazionale,
fortunatamente,
è estremamente importante.
Stiamo lavorando
su questo progetto, ormai,
con molti colleghi anche stranieri,
che con noi stanno condividendo
questa enorme esperienza
e questa grandissima
innovazione tecnologica.
Grazie mille a tutti.
(Applauso)